Oh a woman records what appears to be a
live cow being pushed by a bulldozer yes
she was filming from public land the
farm owner drove up and confronted her
why are you concerned about being filmed
if you have no problem you think this is
a legitimate business Utah prosecutors
charged the woman with agricultural
operation interference am I free to
leave or am I being detained
you mean thing but she was on public
land they dropped the charges several
months later but what if she'd sneaked
onto a farm to record what she
considered animal abuse more than a
hundred such investigations have been
done activists pose as farm workers and
secretly record the way animals are
treated an animal rights group released
this undercover video of the dairy farm
it shows workers hitting kicking and
throwing young calves we are not showing
the most disturbing parts of the video
farmers upset about these recordings or
persuading politicians to essentially
outlaw these undercover investigations
the controversial AG gag law an AG gag
law our activists talking farms to try
to capture something that the public
doesn't understand kay Johnson Smith
speaks for a farm group that supports
the AG gag laws though they don't call
them that we'd call it farm protection
farm protection what about everybody
else why do you get special protection
the agricultural community is the only
business community that this sort of
tactic is really being used on right now
I'm an investigative reporter I can't do
my job if there are laws that prevent me
from showing things nobody believes that
if you don't see it these activist
groups want to eliminate all of animal
agriculture Brittany you're holding a
dead body
this group livestreams its protests on
Facebook you saw a dumpster with
hundreds of dead bird many of the
activists stormed into the farm some
stole some of the baby ducklings we were
just able to rescue
almost 30 baby ducks others chained
themselves to the entrance of the farm
later the activists released this video
of the 30 stolen ducklings adding music
and showing the birds running around
apparently happy they stole those docks
after seeing this earlier undercover
video of injured Ducks at the farm Mercy
for Animals says their undercover
investigations have led to criminal
charges AG gag laws often prevent such
investigations which is why farm States
passed them a bill making it illegal to
apply for a job in a farming operation
under false pretenses but what about
free speech a gag laws chill speech
lawyer Amanda Howell speaks for the
Animal Legal Defense Fund a group that
says AG gag laws are unconstitutional
and they did get several states laws
struck down Iowa then just passed the
new law AG gag 2.0 a bipartisan bill
trying again to stop people from lying
to get onto farms these groups are
exposing issues that are happening if
they really cared about animals they
would stop it right then instead they go
weeks and months without reporting
anything to the farm owners that's true
this investigation went on for months
agricultural groups are now pushing laws
that would force activists to report
abuse quickly
why don't they they want to make their
movie they want to make their
sensational video it's because they care
about the animals that they want to show
that that's something that happens every
day on these farms consistent constant
abuse a company can say this this is a
one-off this is not just discrete actors
this is company policy they say they
don't want to just correct the abuse on
that farm they want to change all
farming practices what they really want
is to stop people from eating meat milk
and eggs do you want people to stop
eating meat I want people to act in
their conscience but you didn't believe
it's with the question do you want
people to stop eating meat or eggs I
think that
again I are we asking sorry are we
asking me personally or yes use Animal
Defenders she never did give a direct
answer workers at the turkey farm
abusing the birds animal rights
activists have exposed things that need
exposing Walmart now taking a stand when
it comes to the treatment of farmer
raised animals how else would you have
made these changes without sneaking into
your farms well that's just say that
farmers can't be trusted and I think
that everyone in the past some could not
there are bad apples in every industry
however I would say 99.9% of farmers in
America they do the right thing every
single day farming isn't always pretty
[Applause]
[Music]
people have some right to privacy no I
think we should all be worried when
corporations are supporting laws that
impinge our right to free speech we
should worry whatever you think of the
activists and I have problems with many
of them government shouldn't pass
special laws that prevent people from
revealing what's true